the kid would always pull their eyes
down
and and that's something that i often
thought about
and as i pushed my eyes up in the mirror
you know i thought
that was the answer to everything
[Music]
my condition is treacher collins was
something that i was born with
i wasn't born with any cheekbones so
that's why
my eyes appear the way they do
and i wasn't born with all the parts of
my ear so i've got the
i call them my little bath sims and ears
it's also affected my jaw
so my jaw's a little receded
and and and that's about it really for
treacher collins
when i was born my birth parents decided
that they needed to go their way
and i needed to go my way my adoption
report
says that jonathan lancaster was born on
the 31st of the 10th
1984 both parents were horrified by the
child's appearance
both parents felt no maternal bond and
both parents left the hospital 36 hours
later
leaving the child behind and
and and those words you know it's
something that's
this was obviously stuck with me and
um you know when i had yeah angrier
periods in my life but you know i
focused on those words a lot
and and they cut deep at the age of five
on the 18th of may 1990 um i was
adopted by an incredible woman um
called gene she never shied away from a
conversation
even the difficult ones about my face
and my birth parents
and yeah she she just gave me this
incredible foundation this incredible
love for me to
live i was totally unaware how cruel
people could be
i started noticing people groups of
people
you know one would see me and they would
second look me
and then they would nudge their friends
the people that they
were with they would point they all
would look
some would laugh some would just stare
the kid would always pull their eyes
down and that's something that
i often thought about and so i started
to look in the mirror
as a child and i always used to push my
eyes up
and to try and make it look like
everybody else's
and as i pushed my eyes up in the mirror
you know i thought
that was the answer to everything girls
would ask me out as a dare or as a joke
um and and i never really exp i never
experienced
any sort any form of dating any
sort of relationship that
snowballed into thoughts of i'm never
going to be intimate with anybody i'm
never
going to have a family i'm never going
to experience love
because i look like this if i had a face
like yours if i had eyes like yours
i'd be happy by the time i was a
teenager i hated my face
and i didn't want a surgery to improve
my face
i wanted the surgery to have a new face
we live in a world obsessed with image
and obsessed with looks
and for somebody growing up with
treacher collins somebody growing up
with a facial difference
i felt like i i didn't fit in and
i had to go above and beyond
to make friendships and then 16
17 18 and i discovered alcohol
so me and my friends would drink and i
would drink excessively and again
just do anything to entertain them
always at the expense of
my own well-being my own health and at
that point in my life
i had no goals no ambition very much
hiding away at home
i started to think that i didn't belong
in this world
and when i had those thoughts
i never thought about i'm going to take
my own life
but i wanted to be in an i wanted to be
in a car accident
and i wanted to as horrible as it sound
i wanted an illness
and to take me out of this life and even
saying that
um you know i kind of feel guilty i did
have incredible friends
um and one of my friends got me a job
working in a bar
my first night at work it must have
lasted an hour and i
heard everybody talking i heard
everybody laughing and instead of
serving people
and i started to hide away got a taxi
and went home
my friend pushed it and made me go back
and i did and then
a girl called beth started working in
the bar
and i
i got butterflies every time i saw beth
and she loved morrissey
radiohead and she was skinny jeans and a
beret
a big red plastic heart and she did
art and dance and i just thought she was
the coolest person
ever to walk the earth and i properly
fancied
the pants off beth one night she came up
to me and she's like
jenna do you fancy going out for a drink
sometime
and such casually is like yeah if we're
all going out for a drink you should
join us
and she was like nerd just just me and
you
and and in that moment i proper wanted
to play it cool
but i was like so gideon and so excited
i was like oh yeah i'm
i'm free tomorrow in fact i'm free
tuesday wednesday thursday friday
sunday and when do you want to make this
happen
and she was just like let's hang out
tomorrow
every thought which is running through
my head
you know does she want to ask one of my
friends out
am i'm either way in um you know is it
just a friendship thing
is she even going to turn up
why why what i questioned her motives
but she did she turned up and it was
great i was like
this is the best day ever and then all
of a sudden
beth went quiet and she puts down a
glass of wine and she's
she started to get uncomfortable and
when people get uncomfortable
with their words around me i know that
they're going to ask me something about
my face
or my appearance straight away i'm
thinking oh
this isn't a date this isn't cool
this isn't sexy i've got this wrong
and so i'm thinking it's my time to go
it's it's my time to leave and beth's
just
looking at me and she sees me looking at
the floor and she's trying to get eye
contact with me
and she's like jono i find myself
staring at you
all the time and again
i hate being stared at and i and and i
found that quite insulting
in that moment and she's like i find
myself staring at you all the time
and she leans in and she kisses me and
she comes back and she's like i just
love your face in it and and she was
just so casual about it
but and we've often spoken about that
moment since
but to me that moment as casual as it
was for her
i went from feeling ugly to thinking i'm
like the sexiest guy in the world
i'm like david beckham brad pitt
all rolled into one this this was huge
for me
we were in a relationship for a few
months i had a confidence i had a
swagger about myself
and then beth was always full of dreams
and full of goals
and she was like no i i can't do this
anymore i want to go traveling around
europe
and i was like oh right and
it crushed me and then but as
heartbroken as i was
i just had this admiration that was
somebody was
able to just say this is what i want to
do for me
it was my first healthy
relationship i didn't need sex to make
me happy i didn't need alcohol to make
me happy
i didn't need a filter on my phone to
make me happy i didn't need to
push my eyes up to make me happy i
it was really looking at who i was as a
whole
and discovering things that i loved
about
your myself parents did you ever try and
make contact with them again
i always wanted to ask them questions i
always wanted to know
why um there were so many things i
wanted to say and share with them
and and then in my darkest days i wanted
to hurt them as much as i was hurting
too
um so when i'm 24 25
i'd reached the point where i wanted to
reach out to my birth parents
i want to let them know that they're
okay and if they're open to meet me then
that would be incredible and so we
shared that with them
through through a letter
a week or so later we got a letter back
um very clear regarding this subject
we do not wish any contacts further
attempts will be ignored
they both signed it and that was it
and you know i
i cried and i felt rejected all over
again
um but again thinking about my birth
parents
you know it's they made that decision
all them years ago and they've decided
to stick by that
they've done what they felt was best for
them and i respect that
and at the end of the day i will always
come back to
those two human beings gave me life
and for that i am forever grateful every
milestone
that i have in life i i tend to to think
about them
but i guess the ultimate thing i want to
share with my birth parents
is that i am happy and i'm okay and
i'm healthy and
i i hope you are too and what's the
future for you
i used to think that my face would
prevent me from finding work
would prevent me from finding
friendships and love
but it's not about my face
that wouldn't prevent me from finding
any of those things
i'm learning more things that i love
about myself
and as i've done that
i've more opportunities have opened and
presented themselves to me
i've discovered more relationships
friendships i've made truer
deeper connections and then now in my
30s
we don't have any conversations about
surgeries on my face because
i love my face and i don't want to
change it
at all
i mean we've decided that even though
there are some difficulties like that
that our love is stronger than that
and yeah we decided that
you know we just didn't want to not be
together
yeah yeah